now that it's been closer to two months
since the M2 iPad Pro came out and we
finally have some software that can
actually utilize its power is it worth
spending the extra money for the M2
version or should you just get a
discounted M1 that is refurbished or a
much better price I just got my hands on
the Beta release of DaVinci Resolve 18
for iPad and it is extremely powerful
with a ton of great features even things
like professional noise reduction so we
are going to push these iPads to their
limit so we know the M2 is more powerful
in the Mt MacBook Air and pro but in
such a thin and light iPad will it
overheat and not perform any better I
have two ultra fast Thunderbolt ssds
hooked up to each iPad so the media is
external I'm going to start out with
something a little more simple that all
of us edit this is 4K h.265 but I do
have two Luts and 4K film grain applied
so there's a lot of processing that has
to happen and and it looks like both of
them are playing back perfectly smoothly
and it's so cool to be able to open up
projects that I created on a Mac now
let's make this a little bit harder I'm
going to go ahead and stabilize this 4K
60 second clip that's going to use all
the graphics that are available and look
at that the M2 Chip is flying right now
it is almost done bam and the M1 was
roughly at 60 percent almost twice as
fast but of course it hasn't heated up
yet and now let's go ahead and do an
export test I'm going to use h.265 a
Master file so this is 10 bit let's put
that on the iPad and let's see how long
these take bam we are off I'm going to
start my timer right here and look at
that they are actually exporting uh
basically the same speed we have 82
frames per second
82. and look at that the M1 is going to
83.84 there actually saw I hit 85 but
they got done at at the same time taking
a minute 20 seconds lightning lightning
fast now the crazy thing is that we
could actually play back Blackmagic Raw
on an iPad and we can adjust all of the
settings for example I'm changing the
iso after the clip was shot now I'm
going to go into noise reduction which
is extremely taxing and I have both
temporal and spatial enabled let's go
ahead and hit play on here and as you
guys might be able to see we do have
some differences on the M1 version we're
running out two to three frames per
second compared to three to four which
is roughly 25 better now of course if we
weren't doing this much noise reduction
uh the frames per second would be higher
but we are seeing some better graphics
performance now I am going to go all the
way up to 8K but first this is 6k black
magic raw footage and it looks like both
of them are handling well even though
these are are color graded with
different effects we're not seeing any
sort of differences now I'm going to go
ahead and skim through this here and
we'll see does one of them look any
smoother than the other and no
to me both of these are super smooth so
far the M1 iPad seems to be like a
winner if you can save some money on
this thing but now let me go ahead and
hit export one more time we're going to
over sample this into a 4K timeline so
it's going to reduce noise and give us
more sharpness and we are off oh my
goodness guys right away look at that
difference here we have 28 seconds left
compared to
45. wow here we're going at 41 frames
per second compared to 28. so that seems
to be slowing now this is only a one
minute project but both these are flying
through but with the extra processing
that needs to happen with the 6K the M2
Chip bam it is done and the M1 chip is
also done both did this faster than real
time we have 52 seconds for the M1 and
36 for the M2 so so we're starting to
see a difference if you're working with
tougher footage but now let's go ahead
and open up some 8K prores footage ma'am
we are off as you guys see there's four
streams of 4K prores 422 we have some
slow motion footage that will slow down
from 4K 120 prores in here and both of
them seem to be playing back perfectly
fine I'm going to go into the color tab
here we have no issues whatsoever both
perfectly 24 frames per second now when
Apple announced the M2 Chip they showed
off that has prores decoders and
encoders which is really helpful so now
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to go
ahead and hit export and we are going to
select prores because yes you can't
export that way bam we are off and look
at that under a minute on the M2
compared to the M1 which is much slower
and and the M2 take a minute and one
second whereas the M1 ended up slowing
down and throttling because it's using a
lot of CPU and GPU not those encoders
and now it's settled in at five frames
per second but it's going to take
another 11 minutes and 30 seconds it's
already been going uh over three minutes
so that gives us roughly 16 and a half
minutes now that it's settled down in
terms of its performance so if you're
working with really tough footage well
the M2 is a lot faster and no even if it
does get hot it doesn't get slower
because of those dedicated
encoders that are built into it and
honestly I thought that it was going to
slow down and get hotter and maybe
perform the same as the M1 or maybe even
worse because the wattage kicked up so
much so for most people though if you
can save 200 bucks we'll have a link to
Amazon and you can get the M1 iPad Pro
maybe a refurbished model which they
have a great return policy on that I
would probably save the money unless you
know that you're going to be doing some
crazy stuff like denoising raw footage
which not very many people do but now
with Blackmagic design for 95 bucks you
can have the tools that cost 300 on a
Mac and if you're working with something
like prores raw some really high
resolutions you will get the extra
benefit now I'm not gonna wait for this
to finish because it's going to take way
too long but overall I'm so impressed
with this application they're gonna add
more features and now we have something
that can not only edit with desktop
level performance and features while so
thin and light it's on the go in my
previous video use the apple pencil and
the keyboard for control it was great
but you can also link up to the cloud
and I use the cloud project so you can
have a project on your desktop you can
do some cutting and Grading with the
apple pencil when you're sitting on your
couch on the go and everything sinks
together perfectly I wish Apple did this
with Final Cut they didn't they refused
to give it to us but black magic design
did you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comments section below click
above to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos over there this Max
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]